this boatload of asylum seekers came
ashore on the island of Lesbos on Sunday
police stopped us from interviewing them
on camera but this Congolese man told me
Turkish people smugglers promised him
and his wife a free ride while they were
in church for Sunday service this man
from Sierra Leone says he was walking on
the beach as the boat was being prepared
he was told to jump in for free as well
it's unclear if someone is paying the
smugglers to do that on the islands
North Shore a boatload of Afghans paid
$500 each to get out of Turkey their
deals with smugglers had been struck
weeks before Turkey's president Recep
Tayyip Erdogan ordered the opening of
borders with neighboring Bulgaria and
Greece both members of the European
Union what did the agent say to you they
say a mourner is offering yes you were
this was the first day of significant
arrivals since Turkey opened its borders
towards Europe they weren't enough to
create a logistical problem for the
Greek authorities but they were enough
to make many of the people of lesbos
anxious that they may once again face
the sort of uncontrolled refugee flows
experienced in 2015 and this time
refugees would have nowhere else to go
the arrival of a dinghy filled with
refugees at the small fishing harbour of
thermi led to a blockade as local
residents prevented them from
disembarking the Coast Guard brought the
dinghy here after its engine failed TV
cameras were unwelcome and some of this
scene had to be filmed at a distance
police were unable to register other
arrivals at Moria camp the largest in
Greece it too
was blockaded by angry Islanders who've
seen its population grow fourfold to
over 20,000 since the new democracy
government was elected last year people
believe the government didn't act
quickly over seven months there wasn't
any increase in our quality of life
Trust has been lost in the island is
turning into a giant hotspot but other
viewpoints were also on display this
group protested at Coast Guard
headquarters calling for refugees to be
shown more humanity and greater support
a stark reminder that migration is a
defining political issue not just here
but throughout Europe jumps our applause
al Jazeera lesbos